When my kids rushed down the stairs asking me for a hot chocolate
because it's gotten quite cold,
I got so excited
and decided to start making them some marshmallows to go on top.
Started by blooming my gelatin
and then combining some maple syrup and water,
heating that up, adding that to the gelatin with some vanilla,
and then transferring the marshmallow fluff over to a tray
lined with some powdered sugar and aero root powder.
Made sure it was spread all even,
letting that harden slightly for about four to five hours.
Decided to make small star marshmallows,
so I kept repeating that process
until I had all my Little Star marshmallows.
I don't know what it is, but my children don't like whipped cream,
so I didn't make them any,
which saved me a little bit of time.
After I set the marshmallows aside,
I started on my hot chocolate,
combining milk, sugar,
cacao powder. While that was warming up on the stove,
I added some cut up chocolate to that,
kept whisking it until all the chocolate was melted,
and then poured it into their little cups,
topped it with my marshmallows.
They were so excited and wanted more immediately after.